this is not a normal video I have about
20 minutes until the boat carrying me
back to my ship leaves but I'm currently
on a hill in Aloha set in in Greenland
along with John who works for tally post
Greenland and Jakob he always my
translator here and I was also hoping my
microphone inside his cup and the reason
we're here is because this is the
microwave relay site for this entire
town
and by extension everywhere North and
John here has kindly agreed to answer a
few questions this this is going to be a
slightly rough video the largest packets
you can get is about 4 megabits and how
long does it take you to upload some oh
well the upload speed is 0.7 megabits
per second so it takes a horrendous
amount of time to upload anything oh
yeah there's a line of sight all the way
from the south from mountaintop to
mountaintop all the way up here and way
up north so we should actually be able
to see the other relay towers where is
the next relay station decision we send
here ah alright so the next relay
station is about 40 kilometers south of
here from Inglot it's an unbroken link
but of course there can be some
obstructions she's healthy I come in now
she's only going to be extremely cool
yeah that's actually a fun little story
about the next village up it's only 8
kilometers away but there was a huge
iceberg that shadowed it from here so
they actually had no internet this
summer but also if there's a relay
station which loses power down south we
might actually also lose it up here so
there was a whole day where there was no
internet up here due to the relay
station that has some bad batteries I
think it was if there's a Sun station
that goes out all the way up north
there's no signal Shukra beady meringue
with ding-danged a Makita to be sure
they they actually can't pull the C
cable all the way through here due to
these massive icebergs they scrape along
the bottom bottom of the ocean so per
next year they're going to upgrade all
the system they're gonna pull a C cable
all the way from nuke all the way to as
yet which is about 120 kilometers that
way and they can upgrade these
cell towers to carry high speed
connections all the way up to amana as
well my tuxedo pocket all I need to be a
good son Caulfield and yeah during the
winter there's these domes get covered
up fully with ice so they need to go and
John thank you so much
Jacob holding my microphone thank you so
much you're welcome
um that was that was not exactly the
usual sort of a let me turn this camera
right there we go that that was really
not the story usual video that I do but
um thank you very much Jacob here um
just kind of emailed me when I said I
was coming here and said do you want to
film a thing ah thank you you're welcome
and uh let me move that camera there we
go thank you so much that's brilliant
I'm here because of Chris Hadfield's
generator arctic and salty my name is
Tim Conley I have YouTube channel Tim to
the wild I make short little cinematic
travel films don't check out everything
by him and all the other folks out on
this project